and now that i'm older it's not i'm
healthy with my kidneys just like you're
just walking on the street you're like
did i just piss [ __ ] push in the [ __ ]
hello everyone hola miss amigos you're
listening to oh my god
with me george lopez
sport sport and paul
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg
guys it's all about confidence when it's
time for sex am i right
sometimes stress can affect your
performance and ruin the fun
bluetooth.com to the rescue try
bluetooth-free when you use our promo
code omg hi at checkout and just pay
five dollars for shipping that's
bluechew.com
promo code omg hi to receive your first
month free
blue chewable makes you doable
thank our sponsor medterra they cut
trusted effective and accessible cbd
products that support deep sleep
relaxation and relief go to medterra
m-e-d-t-e-r
dot com slash omg hi and enter the code
omg hi a check checkout
for 30 off and free shipping on your
first order so
you know a lot of people take um unisoms
they take uh
uh
uh
doctor prescribed sleeping medications
that you wake up and you'll be
like tiger woods going to a golf
tournament
barefooted uh in the middle of nowhere
um
but all those things um
don't work as well
as what medterra is is has got going on
so 30 off
uh free shipping on your first order and
then you'll see how great
uh cbd regular i mean you get to see how
these things work
in in your daily life of going to sleep
and not waking up um with a hangover of
any medicine or not waking up drowsy you
wake up refreshed and you're ready to
start dancing that's what i need in my
life
that's right
m-e-d-t-e-r-r-a-e uh dot com slash omg
hi and then put the code omg high
and 30 off which is a lot and i think
that you'll find something there uh
consistent and then you'll be become a
med terra
uh user for a long time
i mean no it's that guy that kid is good
man and and you know what's even better
what's even better is like nobody's
gonna know that guy from any from any of
his work i mean somebody really young
because i think he did like zoe 101 he
did some young stuff but this is not a
movie that somebody gets
uh
lightly you know this is a movie that
you have to
[ __ ] baslerman you know does doesn't
do movies all the time but when he does
one
it's gonna be really amazing
you know he just he's just that guy like
every attention to detail and flash but
not overly flash i mean i don't know who
makes movies like baslerman
because it's like um
the the the glitz and the lights and the
way that he shoots a movie
doesn't get in the way of the story
and
i mean that's almost impossible to do
it's almost impossible to do you know
that's why you can have like maybe you
know fast and furious nine where you
know maybe you know some of them were
great i'm sure some of them
are okay
but
the the the the
the cars are the movie not the not what
the people are going through and the
chicks the driving yeah the driving
and you know the [ __ ] nipple pops out
when they're going around the turn
no what a rider on one of the cars
nobody wants to go around you know when
you make a sharp turn and one of my
balls pops out oh you can go slow down
when my [ __ ] wheels came out
so so you know without going into i mean
actually had to see it alone because
i don't think if i would have if i would
have seen it with the people that are in
the area that i'm at it would have been
[ __ ] babies crying and somebody
trying to put the stroller away in the
dark
you know
uh but but uh yeah man i'm glad that i'm
glad that they were able to thank warner
brothers and everybody for
ina my publicist for getting that done i
was the only one in there i almost
jacked up that's how to see if i can
almost
[ __ ] be where i'm at i just couldn't
take it out god damn it
but after i saw the movie i could take
it out i was like shall i do anything i
want them
but you know it's a tale of it's a tale
of like
it's a tale of what these dudes go
through man all these
i mean drugs if you look at all the
rappers that that you know
have been
eliminated have been murdered
you take a gun and it's just it's you
know it's drugs instead of
instead of uh
guns man like those guys there's so many
great young rappers that
over just
them living that life of like flashing
cash and all that stuff like then they
get
they get shot and killed and
it just
it just doesn't make any sense
i mean
i mean there's so many of them that you
don't give a chance a dude to get a uh
this out a discography going what do you
mean like like a body away oh i love
that guy's song he got killed like one
[ __ ] song and you get killed
what have you been doing
well i i first uh last time i talked to
you i was
listening to you because i was going to
take a red eye to chicago oh yeah to go
over there
went out there to chicago police
department to be a speaker
for a fundraiser for
wounded veterans and surviving family
members of deceased cops in the chicago
area
it was a great uh great experience the
guys from chicago tell me what happened
now give me give me the rundown from
when you uh from when you landed
somebody picked you up and then
yeah yeah i listened to you before i
took the red eye for the first time
and you said my wubbles were going to
smell like stale chorizo
and
all bar rag and [ __ ] yeah
and and so i got to they picked me up
the airport we went straight to the uh
straight to the golf course no hotel no
[ __ ] went straight to the golf course
was out there
those guys hats off to them it was it
was drizzling when we got there they
went out there they played golf drizzle
turned to rain i got in a golf cart i
went around
and then the guy that was driving around
says you want to take another tour
and i said [ __ ] that tour let's go back
inside to the clubhouse my [ __ ] pants
are so
where did they have a dinner
where was the tournament at
uh some place there in chicago i don't
know i was lost anyway is there a famous
place there's a lot of famous places no
no this wasn't a big famous place trust
me i know that
and
then uh
i'm sitting there drinking and i got a
phone call
about tickets to a dodger game and
[ __ ] went to the these guys were so
happy so ecstatic the five guys
uh while i'm there with the ball
some guy about the third inning turned
around
and there's only two rows in front of us
there's exactly six people four in one
row and the other row is only two we're
that close yeah i could talk to the guys
in the batting circle amazing and and
and this guy turns around and he just
shuts up he says [ __ ] it is you
kill carrillo netflix a night stalker
and everybody started laughing the guy
we all started laughing i said
okay yeah it's me it's it's cool it's
all right and he then we start talking
and he tells me he turned around slowly
to look at me because we really what
really happened was he recognized my
voice because he follows the george
lopez oh my god hi podcast how am i
possible there you go
listen
[Laughter]
but it was great they took they gave me
tours of the city
showing me all this stuff i thought it
was on a guided tour that campbell
building i want to thank tony la russo
of the white sox the manager of the
white sox hall of fame manager won one
and won the championship in both leagues
one of the very few managers that has
done that a friend of mine i called him
up and i was like you know how do i go
about this you know so reinsdorf the
owner of the the bulls and the white sox
always been great to me
and then i said do i call the dodgers
and i'm like ah well you know they're in
chicago man it's different so i called
tony himself i like i thought it was a
day game so i got him early and then
this is just like a mexican guy he goes
yeah take care of him tell him not to
wear any dodgers [ __ ] i said all right i
didn't tell you
uh
and then uh
and then he goes hey what can i call you
and it's like
i didn't call them back because i got
what i wanted let me [ __ ] you
but uh uh and i have been friends a long
time and and uh
that stadium is uh
you know anytime if you love baseball
anytime you get to go
to a stadium wherever
baseball is it's it's great man isn't it
it was it was great being there there
were a lot of that even the guys from
chicago they were a lot of dodger fans
there and i went with four guys from the
chicago pd
fortunately two of them were white sox
fans the other two were cubs fans so
they were pulling for the dodgers tom
yeah they didn't really give a [ __ ] yeah
but it was just it was just great
uh
the group rick caballero out there he
runs this organization nonprofit to give
these vets and uh families of deceased
cops have helped they do a great job out
there
uh they took me to we went to uh
what i looked it up
one of the top 10 steakhouses in the u.s
gibson's oh gibson's is great
oh nice place it was it was great
excellent they give so gibson so
gibson's used to be
in the 70s and 60s there was a club
called mr kelly's in chicago
and every singer what played there
freddie prinze recorded his album mr
kelly's he was opening for sarah vaughan
and then mr kelly's i remember i went
into the i went into gibson's and i said
where was mr kelly's i heard it was
around here it's like this used to be mr
kelly's so mr kelly's
clothes was a great you know lounge you
could go in there and see
uh uh and see singers and then it became
gibson's but it is gibson's is gibson's
is amazing
excellent excellent food the way they
treated me and and
they they
told the guy there was a we were guests
of a guy that's getting ready to retire
matter of fact i've told he submitted
his paperwork lieutenant from chicago
part owner of a
a private security company so you can he
doesn't need to be a company where he's
making
bucks over there his guests and he
ordered the food he said he looks at me
so what kind of you like steak i said
sure he says what's your favorite i said
rib eye
he's okay he says
let me order i said order for so he
ordered there was a total of
uh
four of us
four of us there
and he ordered
no five of us there he ordered a rib eye
he ordered one of these great big ass
steaks with a bone minute uh
i forget what they call it the cut it is
uh but humongous uh does aaron know
those cuts aaron do you know anything
about meat
the t-bone
no not the big big
no no it's tomahawk a tomahawk steak i
am it's a rib eye but only a chingosau
it's big
he had that he was some other kind of
steak he ordered some fish there was
some lobster potatoes and he had the
people there
cut it all up and that way everybody
could just share everybody got a piece
of whatever they wanted
then it was it at the end the big
[ __ ]
uh carrot cake a big [ __ ] motherlode
ice cream [ __ ]
and the wine was flowing it was a great
night uh guys from chica
it was worth it it was worth it
the guys were great one of the cops rick
caballero
he retired
and he opened up his own bar but it's a
private bar
and you know it's for the cops it's
their bar
you pay
a fee you get your
own uh little
key
to get in there
and you go in there the poor's good the
price is right and it's a private bar it
is it is great you get your own little
key fob
and they take care of each other over
there and you think that he's mad
because you said that that [ __ ]
has a private club here y'all say oh you
get a little key [ __ ] they eat you
all the way in
i didn't experience some cool eating
although it's a good thought it's a real
small bargain if i had a if i had a if i
had a small bar i would put a glory hole
in there
so you could go in there you're like hey
i don't know anybody [ __ ] going into
the [ __ ] oil
you'll meet somebody what side are you
on wait a minute what side are you on
and then i did a podcast for them back
there with them and what did they what
did they ask you
uh just questions general about law
enforcement and they asked questions
about the night stalker case but it was
really just uh
i can't say enough about what they did
and how their operation how it ran
uh and a small world
last year
i was uh when i was having health issues
i wasn't going out much in a small world
are you just big then it looks small i'm
kidding no no no no this small world
one of the guys you know they come out
here
uh
to see the chicago bears play the rams
so last time they were out here one of
the guys from chicago actually grew up
over here and went to high school with
my daughter
oh wow so he called up me says hey i'm
in town from chicago you think you could
you know show us a little around you
know help us out we want to get some
memorabilia from the police department
over here
she calls me up i hook her up go down to
east la station
they got some souvenirs some shirts and
stuff and
then
called up a friend of mine i don't know
if you've ever heard of this place
steven steakhouse sent him down to
steven's steakhouse to eat
and
and so
i'm going and when my daughter hears him
going to chicago says dad she wants to
know all the the itinerary everything i
said sweetheart just i got to go i got
to meet somebody i don't even know who
i'm going to meet don't worry about it i
didn't tell her [ __ ]
so i go over there when i'm sitting
there at the table
right after i get the call from you
some guy comes in and the cop that i'm
sitting with says hey this is jesse
jesse this is kill career and he looks
at me so wait a minute
you're creole the night soccer guy said
yeah he says we were just out there two
years ago at your house not at your
house but with your daughter renee
and
he was one of the guys the guys that i
would say oh yeah but i missed it
so these guys all they knew my daughter
and then i became like their instant
deal they're they're not gonna let me do
anything i mean
so
i've already got some t-shirts some
stuff from homicide getting ready to
send it back to them
uh i'm gonna find some stuff send it
back just say thank you for everything
that we needed an official t-shirt
ourselves yeah hey let me ask you uh hey
i've got by the way next time we get
together if you ever decide to come back
i got one for you grant aaron uh from
homicide the 100 year anniversary oh
[ __ ] 100 anniversary of what sheriff's
homicide
so the killing has been going on for a
hundred years
yeah
and this is good in l.a yeah so i picked
up some shirts for you guys and
uh
we're gonna take over if ever you decide
to come back
okay here comes the big question
which place
is better
stephen steakhouse
or gibson's
which has a variety of uh
accoutrement like the potatoes that they
have at gibson's i mean the porsche
gibsons
because see i don't like i i i don't
like i know you couldn't lie because
stephen
the [ __ ] hey one time it was windy the
stephen steakhouse [ __ ] sign blew up
and said
[ __ ] malibu chase malibu chicken i
either [ __ ] steven steakhouse
okay
i i i'm gonna tell you it's like this
remember malibu chicken at sizzler
i guess i remember that that's a big
[ __ ] hey they got a sister here where i
am then you can go in there and uh
it's on the water
i mean it's not water you want to drink
or look at but it's it's it's
technically the ocean
[Laughter]
all right go ahead go ahead this is
there are different levels you know
there are different levels and and i
understand i'm reading uh when i looked
it up on the internet when i came back
the other day
it said that you have to make your
reservations way in advance to get in
there like weeks in the basket of there
at gibson yeah and steve because we can
get you in the last five minutes
yeah this is a friendly place that's my
that's my home brother no i know but we
still owe him a uh anniversary show we
still need to do an anniversary show
yeah we're gonna try to do what howard
stern does man like he's getting like
his friends to come by people in the
band to come by and play
you know even like i'm gonna be there
there's a concert uh i'm gonna be there
sunday peachy brenton wood he's still
alive you know they closed off the
street in front of the in front of
stevens they closed off the street they
put up things i'm going to be in a they
i got a cabana you know they're getting
the cabana sit in and they're having
full full-blown concert out there
damn man
how old does that do
[ __ ] he looks like he's about 115.
he's you know i saw him i saw him a
couple of years ago over at the uh
at the greek the greek theater
and i didn't know if he was going to
make it through the show he's old
brother then i saw him right there at
the microsoft come in he should just do
ooga booga my [ __ ] take off eh
no he does about he he does a few songs
he each he's still he's still out there
he's still giving it they come out there
one of those [ __ ] hannibal lecter
like a [ __ ] dolly like a hand cart
[ __ ] push
he's like we weekended bernie's brother
i want to check his bowls but you know
you know
you know what i
when i what i what i think about when i
saw this when i saw the elvis movie
is
i'm sure there's a lot of people like
you you know people that saw elvis
he was he was doing those shows man like
two a night i mean
one i mean i mean guys nobody would do
that john does like or he did like
thursday friday
saturday maybe you know
but
they had that dude just working so hard
that if there's anybody that's still
performing that anybody
that had a hit or that's older i would
say
to go see them
because
when you turn that page on brenton wood
there's not another brenton wood around
even though he's an old dude
to pay the respect of seeing somebody i
would see him because
he's not going to be around forever like
these these pages turn they're not going
to be around forever you know the one
thing about the elvis movie too is like
there's no tom jones in it there's no
uh uh there's no other
references to any celebrities no [ __ ]
reference to the beatles there's no
reference to anything you don't you know
you don't need it
because when somebody's
that good or or when somebody that you
really like it's not gonna do it forever
and they pass you know and then that
that that's it so
i think um
as much as i like music like you know
you go and see
people that you admire because you know
one day they're not going to be around
i was you know i've seen brenton what a
few times model is going to be there
here's a bunch it's an old school thing
and and i want to go
uh just to go out and get away and have
some fun
and so it'll be good but i i enjoy that
uh that was my era i love that i love
that music yeah i mean i was thinking
about you recently because i they had uh
santana was out here
he was doing a show i know man
did you go see him i would have got your
tickets to go
no i i didn't i didn't go see him
and i think i was i was busy at the time
but i saw him and you're the first
person i thought of because i know
you're friends with him yeah
yeah yeah and and even even him too like
you know there he's touring right now i
think with everyone on fire
but uh you know i try to see him as much
as i can
you know i fly to vegas and see him and
then we hang out and then
you know but we're always in contact uh
because
it's uh
you know
it's just it's a it's i mean you were in
vietnam when all that stuff was was was
coming up all that music like it's still
connected i think music music more than
books and music more than movies
uh connects because you know it's not
like you're slow dancing with your
vehicle and you go hey remember we read
jonathan
it's always music
it's always music i sit there and tell
hey remember you said that to this one
and then i tell her we never remember
jonathan segal that [ __ ] book [ __ ] i
grabbed that book i said [ __ ] you she
didn't even open the [ __ ] page
everybody was buying that book at work
and she brought it home the [ __ ] book
was like this i said what are you gonna
do with it keep your [ __ ] change in
there
and uh not me never she never read that
[ __ ] book it's always music and you
know what it's always music and it
doesn't [ __ ] matter how many years
have passed by
that that's right [ __ ] still making
i'm 72 years old and i still get follow
with that you know i said still
that that stuff's so weird they got a
commercial on tv
it's a young black couple and they're
dancing together
and then it fast forwards now they're
like in their 70s or 80s
they play the same song and they're
dancing i know even my my six-year-old
grandson says
oh
that makes me sad to see them that it's
so nice it touches him my wife loves it
so
now you know what i said i cried because
uh a black man was with a black woman
you never see that [ __ ] at commercials
anymore
you know
is it [ __ ] way fair all that [ __ ]
all it was all the cheap furniture i
don't think the interracial company
was good
yeah
my dad didn't buy us a wedding gift but
thank god wayfarers around
i just found uh i i know i'm going to a
concert i told the wife she wants to go
where uh
it's at the mirage hotel september 3rd
oh i'm over there
all right i guess i just told her i told
him just right i said hey i just saw it
you want to go let's go i'll get you
i'll get you a room
all right
all right here's here's what i decided
after watching elvis
and and doing this
this thing i'm doing over here and then
having the show with maya
if
nobody knows this
if the show gets picked up for a second
season
i'm gonna go on one last tour and i'm
gonna retire from
stand-up [ __ ] i'm already sad
i just i just think that
i just think that it's i've been doing
it a long time i love it but i think
i think you know
i think uh
it's given me so much but i think it's
just maybe easier to
to live
a little bit of a of a of a normal life
toward the you know i can't say golden
year because my cartoon is our goal
they've been golden
[Laughter]
man you know you don't have kidney thing
but there's one thing
man
just when i started to enjoy life now
you think you're done peeing and some
more piss comes out like it's fine i
can't win in in my in my years of 20 to
40 that bad kid is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] meow
and now that i'm older it's not i'm
healthy with my kidneys just about you
just walking on the street you're like
did i just piss [ __ ] push in the
[ __ ]
man listen
your body will fail you before your
friends and family will that that there
that's the [ __ ] that's the
[ __ ] lesson it's like you'll be
alone
life is too short even if it's long it's
too short i would like to i would like
to uh
to take a summer off you know maybe i'll
take a summer off but i mean you know
i'd like to take a summer off and just
go away and not have to uh
worry about you know getting ready to do
a show or what we're coming out to be
someplace i mean i've been doing it
since
i've been traveling since 84.
so i've almost been traveling 40 years
so
well it makes me sad but if there's
anybody deserving of the choose
you know take time for yourself enjoy
god bless you
oh [ __ ] that
and what would we do the last show at
stephen's thing
yeah here you go
with bretton wood over for brentwood
what do they do they close the street
still they they had a parade over here
they closed the street it's a little
it's a little street right in front of
them that runs it connects atlantic and
eastern because they run uh parallel
right there at the triangle and and so
they just close it off they've got like
a little island right in front there and
the city's giving them permission to
close it off they set it up and
uh
i understand they put 800 a thousand
people there
hey guys it's all about confidence when
it comes time for sex am i right never
right but i'm right about this sometimes
stress anxiety a bad day can affect your
performance and ruin it for the both of
you that's why i always do it by myself
hollow
dot com to the rescue bluetooth tablets
help men achieve harder stronger
erections men combat all forms of ed
because the bluetooth is an online
prescription service there are no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line for
the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of the
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online
bluetooth licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength for your
prescription don't like swallowing pills
no problem here bluetooth tablets are
chewable blue chews tablets are made in
the usa and they prepare and ship direct
so it's cheaper than a pharmacy my
daughter used to watch blue's clues and
now i'm doing blue shoes okay sex should
be the best part of your day you're
working hard
you want to get it in you know what i
mean so
blue chew
and it's and you know the thing is that
we're you know let's look at women as
outer space
and the rocket has to get to outer space
and the only the way the rocket gets out
of space if it explodes in excitement
and if you rock it you know
is a cape canaveral everybody's out
there in space
then there's a blue chew is for you
that's what i was saying is it the blue
cheese is fuel and here's a special deal
for listeners try blue chew free
when you use the promo code omg hi at
checkout and just pay five dollar
shipping okay so listen
you can use
bluechu for free
when you use the omg hi
code and you just pay
five dollars shipping what do you have
to lose a night of
that's bluechew.com promo code omg hi to
receive
your first
month
free
med terror was founded by a group of
friends passionate about bringing cbd to
those who love it most if you haven't
heard of cbd
it can promote relaxation sleep and slew
of other benefits
it started by the group of friends that
are passionate about cbd beachbody who's
hanging around the garage topicals like
the hemp infused manuka cream and
on-the-go pain relief roll-on help you
balance your skin
and body and mind tasty sweets like
their full-spectrum deep sleep gummies
amazing support your journey in finding
sleep restorative sleeping and leads to
a
better day a rejuvenated day
modern life is so busy that we often put
our recovery at rest last because there
just isn't enough time
our industrial hemp has grown in america
and is u.s hemp authority certified our
products are third-party tested
non-gmo contains organic ingredients and
grain free omgi listeners get 30 off and
free shipping on their order with
medterra uh go to
medterra.com
omg hi and enter omg high at checkout
that's medterra
dot com slash omg high and enter the
code omgi
at checkout for 30 off and free shipping
they're making it easy for you
to fall asleep and stay asleep longer
and i would say for you to give it a try
let me ask you a question so that dude
that guy was retiring right
um
you know aarp used to be they used to
they said when you turn 50 they would
send you
automatically send you like a
um
a card that's when you knew everybody
would say oh i got my aarp card but
i don't know what it meant retired
people but but nobody retires anymore
really like you know people
i think maybe they thought that 50
people would retire but
nobody's retiring anymore because it
just cost too much to live
um
when somebody retires because you're
retired
yes and honestly like like when you
because i remember when
i graduated from high school and i
wasn't going to college not that a lot
of my friends were going to college but
i remember
the first when i woke up the first day
of the new school year
when i wasn't going to school
it was the first day
from kindergarten to to being a senior
in high school that i didn't have school
and i felt
it felt a little bit sad man
you know it felt sad because
your whole life you have a place to go
you know even if you didn't get the best
school new school clothes or whatever it
still was a thing to go to you saw
commercials back to school
this and back to school that and
everybody wore their their
their thing you saw friends that you
hadn't maybe not seen all summer and
then when you go back
and you're not in school anymore
it's [ __ ] sad i mean so what's it
lovely
i think it's got to be worse to retire
from something
it was a it was a
personal experience i go
from where
for the last 26
30 years i've been working
they needed me i contributed i was a
homicide investigator and i did that and
while i was doing my job i hope i did it
good they wanted me they liked my work
then i leave as a homicide lieutenant i
got 14 people looking for me they're
doing what i when i ask of them
and that's my world
well for 38 years as a cop my wife ran
the house
so all of a sudden i come home
i got nobody to relate to she didn't
understand the business she's not my
friend like those guys were we're not
brothers
and
then i sit there but hey it's my house i
want to you want to pay okay why don't
we paint it this color well no no no
that's not the color i want i want to
paint this well why don't we do that no
no no no i don't this was her kingdom
and all of a sudden i'm stepping in so i
had nothing and i just thought i said
[ __ ] i'm just you don't need me i'm just
a paycheck
the reality this is your domain so i had
to find something
to occupy my time because i did feel
empty i did feel lost
or during where my friend oh they're all
at work still
you know and they're over there so it
was a tough transition
i mean you had a job where like you said
you had 14 people you know i remember
that when i was working in the 80s there
was a guy that and if you remember when
you worked somewhere
all the old head dudes like if you i
worked at a factory in van nuys like all
the older dudes would go to work with
like work shirts and pants like nobody
did like you go to work like this right
but there was a generation from the 60s
70s where guys went to work almost in
dickies
if they worked with their hands or
whatever they went to they went to work
and they looked proper like they worked
someplace
sure and i remember that there was this
old man that worked there
and
at the end of the day maybe like 4 45 he
had a he had a calendar and it said
days to liberation
like he was retiring
he said days to liberation and at 4 45
he
just made this example of like
end of the day he's like oh i will see
you later and the guy opened the marker
and very dramatically
would make an x over that day like and
it and then he had a red square when
when
it was when he was going to be retired
and he didn't speak to anybody just sat
there and worked away all day you know i
didn't know his name couldn't tell you
anything about him
and then when he retired and
um just one day i said like hey whatever
happened to that dude that used to sit
there with the guy would make the x
[ __ ] he probably wasn't working two
months he [ __ ] died
yeah
because he didn't have anything to do he
had nothing to do after so you know you
you're kind of like
like a fish man like you're in the water
and they have to move
and this guy didn't have a place to go
and
he was the same guy making a very
dramatic ex
days to liberate true 100 true story and
he [ __ ] cashed out like two months
because
it's not even that you're going you're
going someplace exciting it's just
you're going someplace you're getting in
your car and you've been doing it for
years and you know your position is
different than his but still that guy
made sure that he had his lunch and he
had his clothes and he had his thing to
do his routine i probably went and got
coffee at the same place every day and
then when you don't when you don't have
that to do man it's
it's a [ __ ]
it's like hitting a brick wall there's
there's no transition like oh you only
work half a day
and then go home and then you know just
come in in the morning and then go home
it's just like one day you're working on
the [ __ ] next day you're not working
fortunately i had when i retired i
haven't a very good friend of mine
partner mine over at uh work we worked
patrol together in east l.a he'd retired
before i did
he he like took me under his wing and
this guy's crazy certified crazy and he
took me under his wing and i ended up
buying a motorhome we used to go
take trips together
and he helped me through the transition
uh because he had been off for a while
he had learned and that made it easy
once i got comfortable now the piece of
[ __ ] has moved way up the chingalis and
canyon lake so i don't get to see him we
still talk
at least once a week twice a week but i
don't get to see him as often but you
have to find something
so listen to this i have a house out
there
that i'm never at clearly i've never had
if you and uh perlo wanted to go in my
house and spend you know a month there
three weeks two weeks i got you covered
we're at a canyon lake in
in la quinta
oh
i was just in palm springs this last
week i i went out there yesterday
[ __ ] i was over there i went to i went
to give a
to do a talk yesterday
if you guys wanted to go and just go and
and stay
who stayed there couple golfers the
guitar player ellen john davey johnston
state stayed there
trevino's been out there and is what
trivial well he used to stay there all
the time he probably stayed there
the first i remember because you talk
about creature of habit like the way
chicanos are so literally also
he had a place he would go to this place
john's on highway 111 like a little
restaurant john's
or john's and right behind there was a
motel so his day was
he would get up he would go eat
breakfast at jaws talk to everybody go
play golf and then by the time it was
getting dark he was up back inside and
back asleep
so i told him hey man
i found this house
for us you know i said i bought this
house you don't have to go over there
because oh no man you know i got my
routine man i said no no no but you
don't have to pay for anything you know
just just like i'm not going to be there
all the time like i bought it so that we
could use it you know you can use it you
come over there you play golf and then
the hardest thing to do is to get
somebody out of their comfort zone
especially somebody like that that like
it's just like a peg in a in a board
here to here to here and then i remember
i was in miami and uh
after like 35 minutes he goes all right
man and then he stayed there
and he was there all the time but
it would be the same thing for me like
i've been in this place i've been here
for i've been in this hotel
for two weeks i played golf twice i
didn't really go out
the first week i was here but that's
just that's kind of the way i am
i don't really go out you know they're
working on the show the nbc show and
there's you know i thought there's
anything really to do there look at some
writing and stuff but but just the beach
is right out here like i don't
i don't i just never i was just never
that guy man it's just never the person
to go
by themselves like i'm happy in here
of course i get my guitars in here and i
got you know about an amp over here and
it's like
i don't know
it's just weird man it's like i'm
not i
mean when i could even even when i
couldn't go out or my grandfather said
you can't go out
now that i can go out it's just kind of
not it's just kind of not me
yeah
i was uh in palm spring history i was at
the
they had this conference at the
margaritaville hotel
so i go down there i go in there
thursday night where is that
let me hold your hand hotel
let me hold your hand it's an old place
when there's a bunch of buildings on one
one facility i go there i talk in the
morning
and then they had me scheduled you know
hey we have a big dinner dance tonight
everybody's gonna be there come and
shake hand do this do that
and
so it left me from eleven o'clock to
about eight o'clock at night with
absolutely nothing to do
and
i just sat there and said you know what
i forgot my meds you know and i could
have lived another day without taking my
medication
and i had one guy old lapd cop friend of
mine he saw me says hey you were my
mentor you my here at this conference
now i'm doing pi stuff and god you're
great it's great to see you
uh
willie sarah cuban from lapd and i told
my i'm going to take off willie i'm
going to go back home man i ain't got
nothing to do here he says
i forgot my meds hey i'll get somebody
to pick them up bring them out here to
you right now
and i said thank you very much don't go
out of your way but there was nothing
for me to do but i'm not gonna
it was too [ __ ] hot to be out there
160 degrees walking around i don't know
anybody to do anything and if i found a
friend i'd have stood there but i mean
i'm not gonna sit there in the room by
myself i just got in the car and came
back home oh you did oh you came back
you went home yeah yeah i was they had
the the i had the room until today
tomorrow but i you were done but you
were done with you were done with the
things that you had to do
yeah i was done speaking you know i
don't know man
i mean
i don't know what the number i don't
know the number aaron
what's the number
what's the number of people to call
eight one eight
jesus
oh i have to look it up jesus
jesus hello i just put it up on the
screen i don't have to ever have to say
it all right put on the screen
because because because
i think that there's a lot of people
i think that there's a lot of people
like us
that
and you know
yeah i'll say that you know it's not
it's not even because of show business
or whatever
i'm sure there's a lot of people like us
that
i mean i had about a scooter in atlanta
uh
and i was using it around the set you
know these couple days i've been off i
could be running around and i'm not it's
just you know it's just kind of i'm 60
[ __ ] two years old too i didn't pass
my [ __ ] hip but it's just it's just i
don't feel my age
but
it's not inconsistent with the way that
i've been my whole life like i would
rather be inside
than be outside if that's but
if anybody i hear you
if anybody is the same way
uh leave us a message and let us know
why you're like this i don't know why
you're like that i mean you are like
that if you have a reason why you think
you're like that
let us know that but gail i got you beat
when i was in first grade i used i have
to take my medication in first grade to
[ __ ] leave her
[ __ ] san francisco i told her i told
that lady i gotta go i'm gonna take my
pills the [ __ ] where'd i get that from
probably my grandmother i said i gotta
take my pills in first grade because i
was great i was like uh uh on my mom man
like i i had to be home even though halt
wasn't a good place i'd rather be there
than be out i couldn't say having fun i
mean are they were they pills or
suppositories hey i both get it
but uh uh
but i mean
i mean how about that man in first grade
i said i gotta go home and take my let's
say pills
my medication
but i remember that they were holding me
by one arm i was trying to get loose and
i told her to take my pills
but i mean so it's not it's not anything
that's brand new with me
but
it's uh
i don't know man and it's almost like a
thing like here here where i'm staying
there's a lot of couples that are here
they're on vacation and stuff and
i look at myself and i said well if i
had a
if i had a woman here
um
which you know a couple of them wanted
to come out here but they're like oh we
can do so much you know what i don't
want to [ __ ] do anything i'm not
inviting you here to get me out of the
room i'm just inviting you here to
get out of town keep me coming make me
happy the things that the sites you'll
see you'll be like a big follower
you'll be safety you've been saying the
same thing for four days
uh
but but um
but you know
when you're ma when you're married you
want to do enough to not get yelled at
but you don't want to do it all
exactly at least i think i think that's
it
you got to do some
you can't do it all because
you're just short out the other day like
i remember we went to europe and we were
[ __ ] these museums every day and all
these [ __ ] tours and and i was just
looking at this [ __ ] statue and like
a switch went off and i was like you
know what i told i told that i'm i'm
done
i can't look at any more [ __ ] statues
like i can't go to any more [ __ ]
museums
we've been here for [ __ ] 10 days out
of like two weeks haven't done [ __ ] i
didn't bring my clubs and i've i've gone
everywhere you wanted me to go
and we were in this beautiful museum and
it's just like you know what
i
i i i can't go anymore and then i look
at my and my goals can i go with you
then the tour guide says you can't go
back there and say [ __ ] i jumped some
[ __ ] ropes you were supposed to go
over i [ __ ] jumped the ropes went
under went back some [ __ ] way the
employees only that [ __ ] get me out
of here like i just
just had enough it was just that was it
we went to uh we went to europe
on a vacation few years i didn't want to
go uh they've read all about this you're
going to franco in italy you had to
worry about the gypsies ripping you off
and i told the wife i said [ __ ] it put
200 in my pocket let me walk through
compton i don't give a [ __ ] why waste my
time over there
we go
and she wants to go see
with four other couples and some of them
want to go to the louvre
to see the mona lisa
and so my wife says i want to go don't
you want to go and i said dear i've been
married to you 47 goddamn years not once
if you wanted to go to the museum in l.a
what makes you think they got better
[ __ ] over here
you want to go bet there i'm going to
stay here i can stay here and drink with
my partner right
so she didn't go i didn't go a couple of
us stood behind
and
i'm not sorry i didn't go if i want to
see the mona lisa watch it on the
discovery channel i know man
but is it is it a thing to go like i saw
the mona lisa and the coliseum
and i've been in the vatican and and you
know yeah
uh the the
we went to of course we went to you know
that in 93 when we went we didn't i
didn't have any money so we went on a
bit of a budget so ann had this book
like a book of course a book that you
has coupons in i don't think they even
still sell that book anymore probably
not they [ __ ] before the [ __ ]
internet now you could say you could get
a tour here or whatever it's almost like
what groupon was but in a book that you
would buy
and then
we took a we took a
walking tour on saturday and the
priest happened to be from san antonio
so i had worked in san antonio and you
know he was like well you know
tomorrow the you know the pope is is
doing mass here
john paul like the one everybody the
last
the last pope that everybody loved i
mean that guy yeah
so he's like i got you guys two tickets
almost like you know like going and
meeting that guy in chicago that was a
cop i got two on the aisle you know like
so we go there and we're
pretty close man like behind
the bishops
like a couple of roads behind the
bishops
and here this little guy walks in
you know with the it's a pokemon with
the thing the scepter and the whole
thing and
uh white compression socks with some you
know he's in italy so he's got some bad
ass loafers you know slip-ons that
[ __ ] probably gucci whatever i mean
i was like i was trying to get close
enough to see what those shoes were like
and he walks in and literally
he's like just like he's crawling onto
this thing man and he's walking you're
like that's dude they're gonna make it
goes up there and it's silent and
and they started talking and then
probably like
20 minutes in
he gets a little bit of a second wind
and you can see him
almost like
coming coming together more and at the
end i mean he's in his 80s
but
it's like he's the pope so you can't say
like what what did he say
whatever he's reading
has to be good enough like you're not
going to say i can't hey we can't hear
you
yeah
so
that's a [ __ ] pope
and when he walked out
everybody cheered
from the moment he got off of of the
you know i'm not religious what is the
thing that
worried the
off the stage
stage
and
the moment he got to the aisle and
walked out of the doors the same way
that he walked in
people cheered
and not a sound before and i went down
there to try to see him
and try to touch him
and i got in there and he passed me but
i couldn't i couldn't touch him
but
i saw him probably like
uh two feet in front of me
wow
i mean so i mean
i saw
have been to florence
i mean that's a that's an actual pope
um
and then when he when he came to l.a i
was on the road but he flew over he did
he did a mass at the mission where i got
married
and he flew over the house and my
grandfather said that the plumbing was
better when he flew over because the
[ __ ] pokemon
a [ __ ] goes on a second flush now
anything that you know if the door open
right away he's like follow up
you know the door open it doesn't squeak
anymore like i mean crazy [ __ ] people
were [ __ ] crazy
when he came to l.a the guy the guy
played the guitar with no with no arms
with no arms
you know when we went the whole trip was
worth it we went there went to normandy
it was solemn i got to see when they
landed but the whole trip was worth it
we had a private tour we went to the
vatican and when we got back into our
little limbo
the wife who i affectionately call
sister mary clarence she's the nice the
religious one in the family
we got in the car
she started crying hard crying
and just thanking me
for taking her there
that was the whole
trip that it just
and and i was very humbled by it that's
all it took she got to go to the vatican
she was happy and it was
very uplifting for her
so i know i know the good man has a
space for her up there oh yeah she's
going down yeah you'll tell me you wait
wait at the end of the line
how about this
what's that
[Laughter]
he looked like an italian pizza maker
brother
[ __ ] dolly aware
[Laughter]
but um
but that you know has significance you
know
that has significance to to
to her right i mean she's
hey it's almost like if we were go to uh
cooperstown or i mean
you know i played in uh you know in the
all-star game
in new york and
all of my heroes
played in that game and tony perez from
the reds
rode on a bat you know you're my
favorite guy and he brought it over i
mean it's just like i mean if
we you know whatever whatever people
like
you can't
if you're somebody that that if somebody
makes fun of what you like you're
probably not with the right person you
know you can kid about something but
but at the end you know
i'd love to even use the phrase at the
end of the day
if you're not willing to be with
somebody to go do something that they
want to do because it means so much
they're not even part of the [ __ ]
dog collection or mount rushmore
or
or whatever or whatever it is like
you're not going to be with somebody who
has a hundred percent of the things that
you want to do and that's the thing
that's the relationship balances you
know when you're in it you're like can
we go here
or can i go there or can we go here
together i'd love if you if you went
there with me you you gotta you gotta do
the you gotta do that you have to in
order to be in a relationship i think
because a lot of guys like the [ __ ] am i
going to do over there they say no man
but i think that's
about you know
you know with with the internet and all
of the things social media like balance
doesn't seem like
you know it's traditional like it's all
but it's imbalances
everything i don't care
however it works man about imbalance and
you know somebody has their heart set on
something and you're like i'm not gonna
go do that and then they never get to do
it it's heartbreaking
i think yeah it was
we we did it she was happy
i told her okay you did it don't ask me
to take you back to that account anymore
and also yeah if you take pictures like
you know people used to send postcards
and or take pictures but you know
when you're there
like the colosseum like when i went to
the coliseum
it was uh i had never really tried never
been to europe but to go to the coliseum
and know that you're studying these
places that and things that you thought
you would never see i never thought i
would see
david or be at the coliseum
or
you know being a golfer and of course i
woke up early because my grandparents
woke up earlier they give a [ __ ] what
time it was that the british open
started at like five o'clock in the
morning on abc growing up and that i
would watch golf and
it was the only thing on at that time
and that then every year became a
tradition that i would go
to carrillos and san fernando we'll get
tamales and then you know come back when
they open and eat breakfast go to sleep
all day so so
and going over there to go play st
andrews and do all that stuff it's like
it mean it's a lot it means it means a
lot from where we come from right listen
you went to normandy there's there's
nobody going back to vietnam to look and
see because vietnam was an awful awful
war
and normandy you can go there on the
beach which is all also
also
a horrible thing happened there
but in in all the wars but
for a veteran to go
back there
is
is really something but if also if you
were with somebody that said why would
you want to go there you were in the
army and you went to vietnam it's like
somebody doesn't understand what you
have to go and see
the excess of the metal still in the
sand
that was a blockade so that the the
ships couldn't or the whatever was
carried amphibian thing that were
carrying the soldiers and they were
picking those dudes off i mean just the
worst imaginable
landing
you know i don't know if i ever told you
this story george but when i after i
came back from vietnam went to georgia i
hated georgia and they sent me to i
wanted to go back to vietnam i'd rather
be back there fighting because back then
it was still segregated and that's not
the way i was brought up you went to
georgia when you got out
yeah they sent me to georgia you'd get
off base and they had whites only
coloreds only blacks and i'm sitting
there saying where do i go the first
gunner that got shot in my helicopter
was black and i'm sitting there saying
wait a minute this guy could go up there
and fight with me take a bullet in the
back and then
you know he can't walk the streets over
here [ __ ] so i said send me back
vietnam my brother that's not the
country that i'm from
nothing but well they made a mistake and
they sent me to germany by mistake
so i got to germany
and then i met a guy and i started
hanging with him and his wife
and all the gis would go to the local
town where all the ladies were the bars
were the part that's where everything
and all the putas they were all right
there and i'd go with him
to this little town that had one guest
house one disco
one restaurant and it was really small
smallest legal size town in germany
and i went there and i was becoming a
regular i'd go in there and drink and
one day the bar bar waitress comes up
and she says
she's our interpreter and she says gil
hair foster li wants to meet you and
talk to you
this was hair foster league's place
and
he sat down right in front of me just
right across the table look me right in
the eyes what do you look like
he he was big he was a big man calling
stature he was an older man
and but very very firm very stern
looking
and he's looking at me right now talking
to me in german she's interpreting
and he says
i am mr foster link
and i want you to know
because he knew that i was
everybody knew that i was a vietnam
veteran and i was in the army because
there was only about four gi's used to
go to this small place
he says i want you to know
that i'm a former ss trooper
and i had to kill many gis
and i killed many gi's sometimes behind
enemy lines sometimes with a garage
what say you
and i looked at him and never took my
eyes off because this was man-to-man you
know
where's this going i looked him back in
the eye and i said okay
i said well i just come back from
vietnam
where i was forced to kill
vietnamese people
i don't hate all vietnamese people
and i don't i hope all vietnamese people
don't hate me
war is hell
and there are no winners
absolutely no winners in war you did
what you thought was right for your
country at the time
i did what i thought was right for my
country at the time
and that's the way life is he says
does this
he was excited he stood up made an
announcement told to stop the music
and then the waitress says oh gil you
must stand
and he announced everybody in the place
this is my friend
gill
he
is a soldier from the united states of
america
anybody in here wants to fight he's my
friend anybody in here wants to fight
either him
or me
everybody at once
moved forward now
and nobody moved forward and they
started cheering
at which time he announced drinks for
everybody in the house
and it was like giving me the key to the
city i could do no wrong
i had made he had a a daughter that was
married to a lieutenant in the army
whom he hated
and had never stepped foot lieutenant
never stepped foot in his house
because he hated the fact that the guy
was an old ss trooper didn't understand
never been through combat didn't know
anything about it
and he says
i don't need him you
understand you were a man you were my
friend
and i could do no wrong thing
so
that's you know i think i think all
those guys are are gone huh
all the
oh maybe the ss dudes are all
or all have all
died now
yeah
i mean
man that's
and you know back then what was it the
early 70s that wasn't even too far from
world war ii
no and and the base that i was on was a
former nazi base they used to they had
the air filter they had big concrete
hooks they had hooks in the concrete
so at night they would lift them up and
their aircraft would come out because
they were hidden underground
during the day they they made it look
they put uh they flooded it and they
made it look like they had
these wooden cows and [ __ ] made it look
like it was raised land are you serious
yeah they put like cows and made it look
like a like a marshland and then
underneath where yeah
yeah
so it was and and i can remember going
through the nuremburg you go through
this place you still see buildings with
all kinds of bullet holes and [ __ ] you
know it's still destroyed it was it was
something it was fascinating and
like i said i had the key to the city
they treated me like a king you know
it was just good
at uh in nuremberg i think that they
have like
i think that they have a [ __ ] venue
that they used for concerts man like i
think van halen played there
and i was watching something on
woodstock 99
and they the guys were like we played
nuremberg it was [ __ ] more behaved
than woodstock 99
but
it's like those places still like
there's still some of that
some of that [ __ ] around
yeah it was it was fascinating i've
always wanted to go back to both vietnam
and germany
uh
it was
this nice place you know they drink beer
back there we drink sodas
you know their construction workers put
beer in their back pocket they have flip
top bottles and they drink a warm they
don't like cold beer they drink
carbohydrates they don't have anything
they don't have anything cold
and when i go play golf in scotland the
you know not that it's you know
uh but if a caddy loses a golf ball that
guy has to pay
for the drinks that night so you have
these four guys or that two two guys or
four guys that travel
in packs everybody has their own guys so
four guys that travel a pack they get
these guys and they're like whoever
loses a golf ball you can hit a [ __ ]
ball you're like there's no way they're
gonna find that ball that guy's like i
got it and [ __ ] that's your ball
because whoever whoever loses the ball
pays
that night and those guys can [ __ ]
get down man
they can
take a drink over here they i learned
how to say
ish libby dish i love you
i'm glass
a glass of wine please and even ed bear
wine i was drinking strawberry wine over
there some good
good stuff over there in
danka
uh should we go do oktoberfest go do a
podcast for oktoberfest little [ __ ]
let's go i'm ready to go anywhere i'm
just y'all [ __ ] like you know
about it i'm i'm on me
i don't know i will be
[ __ ] black i should be able to do
[ __ ] over there
i'm just excited to see
you know it's been a while even on
camera i don't see that i know man i've
been gone since um
what was the last time the last podcast
was the lojo the asian dude
yeah yeah that was him
yeah
hey uh eric should we take some calls
uh
how
or do we not i mean that's what i
thought was a great hour huh yeah
right no we don't have to we can still
keep talking
yeah yeah it's up to you guys
no no we keep talking
but it's funny it's funny um
you know i was never no
it's funny man because like
i'm an elvis i'm in a kind of an elvis
like a bit of a
an elvis would say nerd they would say
like elvis nerd uh
you know i went to the house in 91 they
called the house
and then i went and took that picture
and a few years ago and the guard was
like
you know nobody knew me in 91 and then
we went there like one o'clock in the
morning with that i'll show you the
picture where the lightning the the
light hit my feet
no um
where was your finger at when it hit you
it was i was doing the pose albert
checked it over my
so
okay
so i take this picture
in front of the gates of graceland
okay
then
i say
let me do a pose that was boring
and look
look where the lights hitting my finger
say one
a light right
a lightning a light beam came down and
touched my finger man
on my finger
yeah
and i mean i can see it
so story don't tell momo he'll tell you
it's an orb
that
that's not no that's not normal i mean
mom will tell you everything should go
to the cover
you can give him a [ __ ] sandwich baby
back ribbon should tell you he's the
second
we take them to tony romo's you got them
all year right
the uh but but
the
but the guard
they have a little guard shack there you
know with that old rotary phone like it
didn't even have it doesn't even have
rotary like you pick it up but it goes
to the house
and in 91
i met this girl at the at the laugh
factory
and she was leaving to florida
and she goes
i work at the house they call it the
house i work at the house
and she goes
you want me to set you up with a private
tour of the house
and i was like
yeah of course and then you know we were
all drinking so late like at two in the
morning she goes at nine o'clock and she
goes but you have to go so she called me
at 7 30 and my hotel was all [ __ ]
fall off also and she's like they're
expecting you at nine like you gotta go
and i was there like [ __ ] man
hungover do i go and i went
and took a private tour of the of the of
graceland
and
you know it was amazing but i'm not sure
when i became like a full-on
elvis kind of nerd but the movie
it's funny man because
it's like you know you know
you were a detective you went to vietnam
like you went to vietnam and you were
fighting for your country
and then you became a police officer
detective and then you're fighting for
the people who live in the city
right
so
you you come up and whether you're a
doctor
and or an x-ray technician you're you're
going for the the greater good of the
person the person
might go in there and think that they
have cancer or they think that they're
sick and then
either they you know either they do or
they don't or you you go and tell jokes
in the beginning and you never know
where you're going to end up you're just
going and going and going you know and
guys i want to be doctors and women that
support them or women that want to be
doctors they have this relationship and
then when they get there they break up
it's just there's so many things that
can go wrong
when somebody gets what they want
and
in this movie
it's like this dude
was there to
entertain
and he did
whatever he had to do to do that until
he couldn't do it anymore i think that's
i think that's the message of that very
unselfish man
you know it sounds like i i can't wait
to see the movie he laid it out like
that like
like
it was all about you know and they show
the people that were saw i mean they're
all [ __ ] quick they're just like that
with anybody i mean they're like that
with kim karda whoever whoever
but
you don't
in that day without social media like
it was different so you know these guys
j i would say james brown probably did
the same thing that they that they get
in life to their to their to what they
do but it's not them and they don't pull
back from it he could have pulled back
from it but he i'm sure james brown
could have or all the people out there
i've got i i've got to be
totally honest i i sit there
there are people i am sure
that
do everything to pull you to do
everything that you do
to make you do the max that are pulling
at your strings because they want
something
and
i tell every one of my friends
uh i
i love the man i respect them uh
but
i don't need to pull strings i'm i'm
extremely happy
uh the way life has
been to me
and i can see
people tugging at you
you know and then and it's
and it's tragic that once you get that
big
you know unfortunately that's the price
that some of these uh
entertainers pay
because they're everybody's pulling at
your at your coach streets everybody
wants a piece of it they want a piece of
the action they want a pcu just because
they know you they they can do this
they'll drop your name they can do more
shows and it makes
more entertainment because in your
business uh i just said this to momo the
other day
laughter
is the best medicine in the world
it is
so you have no idea how many
hearts souls
you touch
with your comedy
yeah i mean i i get around you
and for an hour and two hours when we're
doing this stuff i forget about every
other problem in the world i could give
a [ __ ] less about anything going on
because it's fun it's laughter and that
soothes the soul of all of the stories
man like you know we were out there
i can't i was probably 2005-ish
and you you
when you got to this place we were
shooting uh promos for
uh my first hbo special so when you got
in the door closed behind you
and then they had a dresser and i did
some other stuff cnn a history of comedy
stuff in there and then when i came out
there was an african-american guy
walking and he saw me and i waved and he
waved and i told the dude hey man stop
man let me say hello to this dude stop
got out of the car took a picture with
him that dude had lost his grandmother
who was like his mother
and he was
thinking about committing suicide
and
he knew that i was raised by my i mean
we i got out of the thing and and said
you know i know you were raised by your
grandmother i lost my grandmother
hey man i'm i'm so sorry man but you
know and we talked we took some pictures
and then he posted on instagram that
he was gonna he was gonna end it
because he didn't think you know he
could go forward and me waving to the
glass he thought oh he's gonna [ __ ]
take off and then i stopped and got out
which i did a lot you know i did a lot
in the beginning
and uh
even in even in denver i had this
[ __ ] show man that my manager booked
me in
and was [ __ ] all the way i remember
security
in the old denver arenas probably like
five thousand people that people [ __ ]
yell at me from the beginning and i look
and i remember i don't want to open an
old
[ __ ] wound
but i said take a good look at me
because this is the last time you'll see
me and then when we were leaving there
was a girl that was holding a sign that
was crying
and i said stop the car and i got out
and i talked to her and i told her a
sign whatever i had to sign i told us
it's not a big deal
don't worry about it you know
you'll be okay we'll be all right and it
got a little bit in the press back then
but
it's like listen man if you're gonna
live your life to be worried about what
people are thinking or whether it's
going to be in the press or do whatever
the [ __ ] i do way
you don't even have to verify it
i don't do any i do all the stuff i do
without
wanting any attention from it and the
reason you know they're like everybody
has a podcast the reason we do this is
because
it's fun man
it's fun to be able to [ __ ] sit here
with somebody that is that i admire that
i love making laugh and that people
[ __ ] love it that even you could be
at a [ __ ] white sox game and some
dude's like hey [ __ ] that okay
[ __ ] my [ __ ] thing
[ __ ]
beefeater
bb squasher
that's what she called me beef squasher
i still get emails hey beef squasher
instagrams how you doing beef squash i
haven't told them
that i wanted to yeah
i haven't heard but i mean but i mean
it's the it's the freest
form of expression
uh to be able to sit and talk and and
say to people
even though it doesn't look like there's
points
in the last hour and 15 minutes there's
points in there man there's always
points in there
you know i can remember one of the
guests you had on
was uh his first name is leo maybe his
last name is gonzalez i don't know he's
a guy that does all the uh
ticked out
yeah uh things on there
and he remembers when you were in san
jose or bakersfield or someplace
where he was a kid he admired you so
much
you went by and you stopped the car
just to go up and say hello and sign his
honor and he's never forgotten that well
i remember someone else
i could tell you that nobody does that
yeah i know one guy that doesn't do it
and he's sorry today he hasn't done it
that's eric estrada
well
i mean
you know the expiration date on those
veneers is about to [ __ ] run out
but listen i don't i don't throw
chingazos but the next time i see eric
estrada
they'll be [ __ ] he'll be a [ __ ]
doctor beecham's the [ __ ] next
morning
nothing more fitting
just to [ __ ] lay that dude out
all right anyways
all right aaron
you're good
you're watching oh my god hi podcast to
[ __ ] watch erica's trying to be like
white out
[ __ ] well just put it out there
hey you know where to find me eric
estrada do you want something
you can't find me here you have to wait
till the beginning of august but i'll
[ __ ] you over here
and that's real
in your old ass
1971 rolls-royce with all the white
walls all gray and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
if i went to jail even if i even if i
thumped that dude and i went to jail i
think
i'd get the biggest piece of of
salisbury steak on wednesday
[Laughter]
all right let's go man thank you
everybody for watching big girl you want
anything we want to thank anybody that's
some hey i just uh i reiterate thank you
the guys from chicago was a great gig
thank everybody thank you george for
hosting this thing and uh i'm just i'm
just happy to be a small part of it
small part of your world
you